- [Mark] All right, Ally.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Ally, where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- Alaska.
- [Mark] Alaska?
- Yes.
- Really?
And tell me about your childhood,
do you have both your parents growing up?
- No, I had my mom and my
dad was around 'til I was two
and then he disappeared
from my life until,
first time I saw him
again was when I was 14.
- [Mark] Okay, and how was your childhood?
- Well, on the outside
looking in, I had everything.
All the opportunities, my
grandparents were well-to-do.
But my mom was a cocaine
addict until I was eight
and then she got clean.
But my sister, she's four and
a half years older than me,
she was sexually molested
by her Campfire teacher
that the school had for the
summer put on, and quite badly.
And so kids, how they cope
with that, they reenact things.
And so from the time I was three years old
'til nine years old,
I was sexually molested by my sister
and any neighborhood kids
that she could involve.
- [Mark] Really?
- Uh-huh.
- Yeah.
- Very sexually molested.
(laughing)
- [Mark] And this went on for how long?
- From three to nine.
- Three to nine.
- And the reason it
stopped when I was nine
is 'cause that's when my
sister ran away from home
and she became a prostitute.
- [Mark] And where is she today?
- She today is in North Pole, Alaska.
And she has kids and
she's doing a lot better.
She still has a lot of issues.
She's drug addict like we all
are in my family pretty much.
But she's not really prostituting
anymore for the most part,
but for drugs she might whatever.
(Mark chuckles)
- Yeah
- She does what she does.
- Right.
- But...
She was always the outcast in the family
and I was considered the good kid
but I was the one who was always in jail.
I've spent half my life in prison.
I wanted to be self sufficient,
well let me back up.
So at 11 years old, I got
addicted to cocaine, I'd snort it.
And then by 12 years old, I
was addicted to crack cocaine.
- [Mark] Who introduced you to that?
- That would be one of my uncle's friends
at a Christmas party at
my grandmother's house.
(Ally chuckles)
- Great.
- And that was, Mike Chatly was his name.
And we would sit down in
the basement and play pool.
I loved hangin' out with
my aunts and my uncles
'cause they let me drink and stuff,
it was a different time back in the '80s.
- [Mark] Yes.
- And so by 12 years old,
I was addicted to crack
and I couldn't function
with kids my age in school.
So I dropped out of school in 7th grade.
And so I have basically
a 7th grade education.
I did go back when I was
22 and got my G.E.D.,
but...
I really have no book smarts
- [Mark] Yeah.
- From that age.
- [Mark] So where did
your life go from there?
- From there I moved out of my mom's house
and I went, I grew up
in Fairbanks, Alaska.
And when I was eight, my
mom got clean off drugs
and we moved to Anchorage.
And so when I was 12 and I
moved out of my mom's house,
I went back to Fairbanks
to stay with my grandmother
and I had a horse and everything.
But was addicted to drugs,
and I couldn't cope there.
So I took off from there
and I met this guy, Ryan,
and we started going out, he
was a few years older than me.
And he had his own place.
And he was weird.
He didn't physically abuse me
like hitting me all the time,
but he would do weird stuff.
If I wouldn't have sex with
him, he'd fuck my legs.
He would put plastic bags over
my head and poke holes in it
just to watch me suffer.
He would do really weird stuff to me.
But I got away from him and
I went back to Anchorage
to be with my mom.
And I was like 15 at this time.
And my mom and my stepdad
did ballroom and line dancing
so I grew up doing that too.
And my mom had a junior team
and they would travel all over
the states and stuff competing and stuff.
And my mom also had a
dance apparel business,
and it's called Showstoppers Dance Wear.
And so she had me working for her
while her junior team,
I think they were in Paris or something
for a dance competition.
And my sister came by and we emptied out
my mom's cash register
(Ally chuckles)
and we went and got a bunch of crack
and we were partyin' at the house
and my sister went outside
for some odd reason
at like four in the morning.
And I heard her scream
so I went running out,
and there was Ryan.
And he snatched me up and
took me to Valdez, Alaska.
And for like two weeks he had me in a tent
in Valdez, Alaska at a campground,
and it was my birthday.
And I wanted to call my mom
and tell her I was alive
because nobody knew what happened to me.
And he got upset by it and he was drunk
and he put a gun to my head
and somebody seen it and called the cops.
So for like three hours they tried get him
to take the gun away
from him but he didn't.
He cocked it and pulled
the trigger, and it jammed.
And so they took him to jail.
And from there, I ran away to Hawaii.
And in Hawaii, I'm a crack head,
and they didn't have much crack there.
They had ice or about to.
(laughing)
So I started doing meth.
And I quit smoking crack.
And I started going from Maui to Oahu.
I would buy a couple
ounces and go back to Maui
and sell 'em and then go back.
And I had a boyfriend
who was on work furlough,
which is you're in prison
but you can go out during the day to work.
And he's much older than
me, 18 years older than me.
And his name was Al.
And his actual name is
Louelle and he's Hawaiian.
And one day when I was in
Oahu picking up my stuff,
I was pregnant by this
time with my first child.
I was 19 or 20 by this time.
And the guy seen a
picture of Al in my wallet
and he was like, "Why
do you have a picture
"of this guy in your wallet?"
And I said, "That's
the father of my baby."
And he's like, "Oh shit." (Ally chuckles)
He's like, "No, no, no, no,
I'ma put you back on a plane
"and from this moment on,
we don't know each other."
And I'm like, "Why?" (Ally chuckles)
And he's like, "Because I don't
wanna get my throat slit."
And I was like, "What?"
And I had no idea at the time
that the guy I was pregnant by
was a huge, very well known
drug dealer in Hawaii.
And (Ally chuckles) I just had no idea.
I thought that I was
somethin', but I was nothin'.
And anyway, he got out of jail
and (sniffling) my life
with him was crazy.
He was a huge drug dealer
and...
Basically I stayed holed up in a house,
pregnant and I never seen him.
His runners would bring
me food and whatnot.
And I was kind of just goin' crazy.
But I was crazy for him.
He tried to run me down.
Or I tried to run him down one time
when he was trying to get away from me.
But basically, the cops,
because they knew who I was with,
anytime I was walking down the street,
they would literally arrest me,
take me to jail for no reason.
And they couldn't hold
me more than three days
but they would interrogate me
and try to get me to give him up.
When I gave birth to my kid,
I gave birth with cops
in my delivery room.
He couldn't come to the hospital.
And then they took my baby away from me.
All because of who he was.
And I had no chance of
getting my kid back,
which I didn't know at the time,
but they didn't call.
I didn't wanna tell my
family that I lost my kid.
So I lied and I acted like I had him.
But my mom and my
grandmother came to Hawaii
to surprise me one day and meet the baby
and they found me walking down the street
and I was probably like
90 pounds, all strung out.
And they wanted to know
where the baby was.
And that's when I told 'em I lost it.
My grandmother had to sue
the state of Hawaii to get him back
'cause they had an adoption ring going on.
(sniffling)
And she did get him and
she has him to this day.
When I was in Hawaii,
my babies dad, he was wanted obviously.
And I wanted to get off
the island with him somehow
and I just started thinking,
"Gosh, I could just make
you an I.D. or something."
And I found out that I
had this amazing knack
for making I.D.'s, I could make I.D.'s.
(Ally chuckles)
So I started making I.D.'s
and birth certificates
and Social Security cards
and anything else that I could recreate.
And in the meantime he got busted.
And there's a huge story behind that too,
but I guess I don't need
to go into all that.
But the cops on Maui were dirty.
And I had internal affairs
when I was in jail come
try to speak to me to
find out what I knew.
But I didn't know anything at the time.
I didn't find out 'til later on
that my baby's dad had some sort
of indisputable evidence
against the police department
bringing in drugs,
making contract killings,
things like that.
And he worried that we
might have to go into hiding
and stuff because when
they were to catch him
and arrest him,
one cop in particular,
his name was Rocky Silva,
he would shoot to kill.
If he found us, he would start shooting,
and we didn't have to
have a gun or anything.
He raped one girl
(police sirens blaring)
with a nightstick in the
butt thinking it was me.
(police sirens blaring)
Just because he had a vendetta against Al
for having this evidence or whatever.
A rookie cop was the one
who busted my baby's dad.
Which is why he's still alive right now.
But he's still in prison to this day.
It's been
(police sirens blaring)
18 years and he's still in prison.
He has four first degree attempted murder
to four police officers and
25 first degree assaults.
And...
Like I said, internal affairs came
to visit me when I was in jail
because they wanted to know
what I knew about this evidence
that he had, which I didn't
know anything about, Thank God
'cause I'd probably be dead right now.
But the reason I went to prison
is because when I was
trying to make I.D.'s
for us to get off the island
and I found out that I
was really good at it,
I started thinkin', "Wow I
could do somethin' with this."
So it was Kmart at the time had this thing
they called instantaneous credit.
And you could go in with a name,
a Social Security number, and an address
and you'd find out if
you were good for credit.
And if you were, then you
could shop for three days
with that receipt until the
actual card came in the mail.
So I would go rob people's
mailboxes for their information
and then I would go and I
had my little printer setup
in my car with my inverter
to make I.D.'s right then and
there if I got the credit.
So I would do that and then
I started finding checks
in the mail and I started doing that
'cause you can get cash back.
You can write a check out and
return the item the next day
and get the cash back.
And it just gradually grew
until I was rollin' in a 2002 Lexus
and I was 21 years old.
I had a kid that I didn't
have because my grandmother
was at this time battling for him.
But I was so strung out,
I just was outta control.
But when I got busted,
they made a new law just for me basically.
Because when they busted me,
all they busted me with was
a bunch of unopened mail.
And actually a lot of
people think that's federal
but it's not, it's not federal
until you open the mail.
And because it wasn't opened,
they really didn't have much
but a 30 day thing that
they could get me on.
But the girl that I was busted with,
her statement that she made
got it to where they made a
whole new law just for me.
A new identity theft law,
which they say is worse than manslaughter
because it's premeditated,
and it carries up to 20 years per count.
Well I had 72 charges of that.
So my first public
pretender, public defender.
Said I was gonna do 40 years flat, period.
I was only 22 years old.
I'd never been to jail for anything other
than I had one second degree assault,
which was bogus too while
I was with my baby's dad.
We were robbed at four in the
morning by three Samoan guys.
And they came in beating us with bats.
I was eight and a half months pregnant.
And to make a long story short,
I slit one guy's throat and
I stabbed the other two.
In the mean time the second
guy got the knife away from me
and I grabbed back by the blade
and I cut all my fingertips off.
(Ally chuckles)
And so when the cops came
and I was standing there with the knife,
and there was blood and there was a circle
of people all around me,
and all four of us went
to the emergency room.
Me and the three guys that robbed us.
Because we all had stab wounds.
And I had passed out or something
because when I woke up I
was handcuffed to the bed
and I didn't understand why.
'Cause I was at home,
I was eight and a half months pregnant,
I was tiny besides a big
belly and I'm a female.
And there's three huge Samoan guys
and I'm handcuffed to the bed.
And I'm hearing them ask
if they wanna press charges against me.
And thank God they said no,
but I went to jail that night.
My baby's dad bailed me out
for 24 thousand cash an hour later.
No bail bonds, just $24 thousand cash.
And I have a second degree
assault on my record
but I've never been to court for that,
never was convicted of it.
But I have it on my
record, which is bogus.
The reason that they took me to jail
is because of who my baby's dad was.
That's the only reason.
(police sirens blaring)
Rocky Silva was the cop on duty that night
that took me to jail.
This is before my baby's
dad was wanted again.
Right now he was just still on parole.
He had just done 10 years
in jail and had got out.
So where was I before I
went back in time to that?
I was talkin' about...
Oh yeah, so I gave birth to
my son in the delivery room
with all the cops in there
tryin' to get my baby's dad.
But he didn't come to the hospital,
I lost my baby that day.
My grandmother came.
She was battling for the boy,
oh yeah, and I ended up in jail.
And the second lawyer
'cause I fired that lawyer,
also said the same thing.
I was looking at 40 to 60 years flat.
So my mom, I love her to death,
she's never judged me, she's
always been right there for me.
She had a fundraiser
with her dance students
and they raised up $10 thousand
to get me a real lawyer.
This whole time in Hawaii really,
my whole family was behind me
and they lost everything pretty much.
My grandparents, the money that they spent
to sue the state of Hawaii
and get my son pretty
much killed their business
that they had for 55 years.
They eventually had to shut down
'cause they couldn't afford it anymore.
My mom put everything she
had into getting me a lawyer,
which was great, I only
ended up getting charged
with five of those identity
thefts in the first degree.
And they carried 20 years per count,
so that's 100 years plus
five credit card thefts
so that's 122 years is what I got.
(sniffling)
I did get out of jail with
a 10 year probation thing,
with the stipulation that if
I screwed up at all within
this 10 year period that I had to go back
and I would do no less than 50 years.
I had a 50 year mandatory
minimum sentence.
But the judge could charge me
anywhere from 50 to 122 years,
which was my max sentence, but no less.
Well,
(sniffling)
when I got out of jail,
Maui didn't want me to
leave the island of Hawaii
but my mom had the mayor
and the chief of my tribe,
I'm Native Alaskan,
Athabaskan Indian Wigan Tribe.
(sniffling)
Had them write letters saying
they couldn't legally hold me
in Hawaii 'cause I'm native to Alaska,
they can't hold me there.
And if the probation office
was willing to take me on,
then they couldn't legally keep me.
So they gave me a 30 day travel pass
in which I had to convince
Alaska to take me on
as a person on probation,
overseeing it for Hawaii,
which they did, on the
27th day, accept me.
In the meantime I put
myself into treatment.
(sniffling)
And I was okay for three years.
I graduated treatment and whatnot.
I was okay for three years,
and then I screwed up and
started making I.D.'s again,
started doing drugs and,
(sniffling)
This time I taught everybody
in Fairbanks how to make I.D.'s
and there ended up being a huge mail ring
that they tried to say that
I was the ring leader of
but I beat that case.
And I ended up going on a shopping spree
with my boyfriend in Anchorage.
(sniffling)
For three days.
And it ended with me feeling
like I needed to go home
'cause by this time I was
not going to probation,
not checking in, and I
was a wanted fugitive
out of Hawaii at this point.
And I knew I was screwed, if
I got caught I was going back.
I was not gonna
(sniffling)
do less than 50 years.
And so I was scared, I
wanted to go back home
and just stay holed up in my house.
And my boyfriend for
whatever reason decided
to publicly beat me up.
Just pulled me out of the car
and start whoopin' my ass.
And somebody called the cops.
Well on our way to Fairbanks of course,
I made like four I.D.'s for him
'cause all of the checks
we had were in guys's names
(sniffling)
And
(Ally chuckling)
it's not funny but it is kind of funny.
I had a printer of course in my car
so I could print out
the I.D.'s and whatnot.
(Ally laughing)
And I had a sticker which they used
as evidence against me on my printer
to show that I had no compassion
(Ally laughing)
or empathy
for what I had done.
It said, "I don't feel like
myself today, maybe I'm you."
(Ally laughing)
And that's not funny but it is.
But anyway so to make a long story short,
I got busted and I had
to do my time in Alaska
for this new identity theft crime I got.
And before they extradited
me back to Hawaii,
(sniffling)
I wouldn't tell them my
name when I got busted
so they booked me under Jane Doe.
But about seven days later,
I don't know why it took so long,
maybe their fingerprint thing
was broken or something,
but it took 'em about a week
to figure out who I was.
But I heard when they said my last name,
I knew it was over for me.
So I got new charges in Alaska
and then I was waiting to be
extradited back to Hawaii.
(sniffling)
And I did my three years in Alaska
and I was waiting to be
extradited back to Hawaii.
I talked to my lawyer in Hawaii
and he said that he had cut me a deal
for a 30 year flat sentence.
So I gave my son up for
adoption to my grandmother.
'Cause up until this
time she just had him.
I had not lost my parental
rights or anything.
But I gave him up for adoption to her
because I didn't think
I was gonna get out.
So for three years I just
mentally prepared myself
to not get out 'til I was an old person.
(Ally chuckling)
So two weeks before I was supposed
to get extradited back to Hawaii,
the in house P.O. comes up to me
and tells me she wants to
talk to me in the office
and I thought, "Oh my God,
they're gonna take me early
"or something, this is awful."
(sniffling)
And she says, "What would you do
"if you were to get out today?"
And I said, "Why are you
making me tell you that?
"I don't wanna think about that.
"I don't wanna think about that."
I stopped taking visits from
anybody, not family nothing.
I just would call my son
on the phone, that was it.
I totally said goodbye
to the outside world.
And I mentally had to prepare myself.
It's a long time.
I like being free, I don't
wanna be locked up in a cage
like an animal anymore.
I get really bad anxiety
just thinking about it.
Really bad P.T.S.D.
But she made me tell her
anyway, which I was upset about.
But I told her and she's like, "Well good,
"you have to go by
exactly what you just said
"because you're getting out in two weeks."
I said, "What?"
And she's like, "Hawaii's
giving you a second chance."
And so I don't know why but my
first reaction was not happy.
I was probably in shock obviously
but I was actually disappointed.
I was like, "What?"
(Ally laughing)
I gave up my kid, what do
you mean I'm getting out?
I was so excited to go to Hawaii
'cause I could smoke
cigarettes in jail there.
(Ally laughing and sniffling)
Stupid stuff, but it took about
24 hours and then it hit me.
And I was like, "Oh my
God, I'm getting out."
And I called my grandparents
and I told them.
And my grandmother was like, "Oh no."
She was like, "What?"
She was like, "You do so well in jail.
"Don't get me wrong, I'm
glad you're getting out.
"But you excel in prison,
"and soon as you have your own free will,
"you just screw up."
And then I'm like, "Wow."
And she's like, "And you don't
just screw up a little bit,
"you screw up bad."
(Ally laughing)
And I'm like, "Yeah."
So,
(sniffling)
one of the people that I had
hurt doing identity theft,
sorry to back up a little bit.
In Hawaii when I first
started doing these crimes.
I didn't care who I did it to.
I was there to take your money.
And a lady came, I had several people,
almost 100 people take the
stand at my arraignment
just to make sure I wasn't
getting out of jail.
And one of the ladies was a lady
that I remembered very well at the time,
spending her money.
(Ally sniffling)
I had put her on the street
and she was a single mother of five.
Her husband had died.
And...
That has stayed with me forever
because I just couldn't
believe I did that to somebody.
So when I did start doing
identity theft again,
I this time decided that I was
going to stalk the obituaries
and hit dead people instead.
'Cause I didn't want to screw
up anybody who was alive.
And although that sounds
really morbid now to me,
(Ally sniffling)
at the time I felt like
I was being very kind.
And I justified it by
(Ally sniffling)
the fact that I wouldn't
just do any dead person.
I picked on dead people that
didn't have any next of kin
who's money was pretty much in probate,
which I consider a black
hole for the government
to take your money.
So I didn't feel like
(Ally sniffling)
I was doing anything very wrong.
I felt like our nation or our America,
or whatever, we idolize Robin
Hood and things like that.
But yet you grow up and be like that.
And you get in trouble.
So I felt like I was Robin Hood,
robbing from the rich
and helping out the poor.
Because I was very, very generous.
I liked buying people stuff
because it's how I got
a lot of my self worth
was giving things to
people, it made me happy.
And...
(Ally sniffling)
so...
(Ally laughing)
The government didn't like that,
they don't like you stealing their money.
So yeah,
so anyway, I decided this
time when I got out of jail,
I wasn't gonna do that again,
I wasn't gonna do
identity theft ever again.
Because when I got sober,
the more that I thought about the fact
that I would stalk the obituaries
and then literally go
rob a dead person's house
was pretty disgusting, really disgusting.
And I didn't really like
myself very much for that.
So I thought the best way
that I could make amends to these people
and these dead people that I hurt
was to (Ally sniffling) never do it again.
And so I
- I know you.
- I pretty much, I decided I
wanted to join the military.
But they wouldn't let me.
They were like,
"Hell no you're a thief."
(man mumbling)
You're the worst of the
worst, you can't do it.
And I didn't just stop there.
For years I went in and
I just drilled them.
I wanted to join the military.
I wanted to do something
different with my life.
I wanted to be a better person.
But they wouldn't let me.
And it seems like as much as
I've tried to change my life,
the only thing that I can do is deal drugs
or I could go sell my ass.
Because this thing about
them changing your life
and doing things better when
you get out of jail's bullshit.
They label you a felon and you're fucked.
I can't do anything that
has to do with money.
I can't work in a Bingo hall.
I can't do anything like that.
I can do construction.
That's the only field of work
that doesn't judge me and my past.
And I can't even work with old people.
I can't really do anything.
Being a thief is really
considered worse than murder.
And when it comes to society
and working and stuff,
they really rather have a murderer
than a thief working for them.
It's just the truth.
Which I get it, I get it.
But so pretty much what
I've done all these years,
is I've dealt drugs 'cause
I don't wanna sell my ass.
'Cause for me I know my sister
was a prostitute for years,
I watched her
(Ally sniffling)
get beat, drugged, just terrible things.
And I don't know if she even
likes herself very much.
But a couple years ago, my
mom got sick with cancer.
And she takes care of my daughter.
I have three kids.
The youngest one I gave up for adoption.
I actually had him for my aunt.
When I found out I was pregnant
I wasn't gonna have it, I
was gonna have an abortion.
But I didn't want to.
My aunt really wanted to have a baby.
So I asked her if she wanted
to have a baby with me,
if she wanted to have a baby.
And so I had my baby for
her and it's kinda crazy
because he came out looking just like her,
which is weird because his full sister
looks nothing like him.
And me and the dad both have
dark brown hair and brown eyes
and he came out blonde with hazel eyes.
(Ally chuckling)
And she's blonde hair, blue eyed.
So it was just kinda weird,
he looks just like her.
But I have an 18 year
old son, my Hawaiian son.
And then I have my
daughter, Patience who's 10.
And she loves me to pieces.
I've broken her heart quite
a few times 'cause I leave.
But I don't wanna drag
her through the mud.
I'm a heroine addict, I shoot up heroine.
(Ally sniffling)
I smoke crack and I do meth.
And...
I wanna be a good mom.
I talk to my daughter every single day.
But a few years back, my
mom got sick with cancer.
(Ally sniffling)
And she lost her job and
ultimately lost her house,
which she didn't tell me at first.
She was not telling anybody
in the family about it.
But I came back to Alaska 'cause I travel.
I'm a roamer.
(Ally sniffling)
I had went to Seattle and then
I came here to California.
And I just missed my kids.
And I left my ex here that I
had been with for eight years
and running around chasing
him all over the world.
(Ally sniffling)
I left him and went back to my family.
And my mom pulls up to this
shabby apartment building,
and I'm like, "What are we doing here?"
And she's like, "This is home."
And I'm like, "Whoa, what
happened to our house?"
'Cause my mom used to have,
she had two businesses
and she was a travel agent for 14 years.
She was well-to-do.
She had a condo in Hawaii,
she was doin' big things.
And (Ally sniffling) so
I was very shocked to see
that she was living in a
tiny little one bedroom,
nasty little shabby apartment complex,
lost the house and everything.
(Ally sniffling)
Lost her really well paying job.
And so she has cancer for the third time.
(Ally sniffling)
And I had saved up a little bit of money
and when I went home, (Ally
sniffling) I gave her all of it
to put towards the rent
because I found out she was
quite a few months behind.
We paid $25 hundred and
the landlord assured me
that she wouldn't be kicked out.
But seven days later we
got an eviction notice.
And I had to move into a tent
with my mom and my daughter.
(Ally crying)
And I always promised my mom
that if she ever got sick,
I would take care of her.
(Ally crying)
But I just did so bad
with my life early on
that I'm unable to do that now.
So I decided, because I
have a flagging license
in Washington, I decided to go back.
Well, let me back up.
Before I decided to go back to Washington,
(Ally sniffling)
I didn't know what to do for my mom.
We had no food, we're living in a tent.
So I resorted back to old things,
I know how to get money.
I went and I did some mailboxes.
And I did a couple checks.
(man yelling)
Which right now, I didn't
have any I.D. I asked my mom.
Okay, in the meantime I was doing oddball
jobs on Craigslist, I was
cleaning houses and stuff.
And I really was doing that, it's legit.
(Ally sniffling)
People would pay me with checks.
But this time work was slow.
I told my mom I had gotten a job.
I went and got a check out of a mailbox
and I
(Ally sniffling)
lifted the ink and I wrote it out to me,
and I wrote it out to her.
And I didn't tell her the truth until now.
She knows the truth because
she's going to court for it.
Because they think that
(Ally sniffling)
that she knew about it.
And my mom has never
been in trouble before.
So now she has cancer.
(Ally sniffling)
She takes care of my daughter
and now she's in trouble with the law
for a felony charge.
(Ally sniffling)
And I wanna go back and turn
myself in but she won't let me.
(Ally crying)
Because she knows that if I go down again,
I'm gonna be doin' a lot of years.
And we don't know how
much time she has left.
And so I promised her that
I would go to Washington
and I would get a flagging job
(Ally sniffling)
and I would help her,
I would send money until I
could get into an apartment
and I would send for them.
(Ally sniffling)
Well about two months
after I got to Washington
and I was working and everything,
my flagging license expired.
So I couldn't work anymore,
I had to get a new one.
Well (Ally sniffling) it
used to be really easy,
you just paid $55 and went
to an eight hour class
and you got your flagging card.
And now you have to enroll
in college to get it.
(Ally sniffling)
So (Ally sighing) I'm a
procrastinator needless to say,
I found an easier way.
I was living in what they call The Jungle,
it's Tent City in Seattle.
And I know a lot of people there
and one of the big dealers there,
he was my good friend, he said,
"Look you can partner up with me."
(Ally sniffling)
And you send your mom money.
So I was sending my mom like
$100 a day dealin' drugs
and he got busted, he went to jail.
So it's territorial there.
I was a white girl and they're
all Vietnamese pretty much.
And when he went to jail,
the Vietnamese basically put me in a room
and they all had a meeting
where they decided who
was gonna take the dope
and the money from me.
And they told me I couldn't work anymore,
which I still did work,
but I had them shooting guns in my tent
at two in the morning
and things like that,
threatening me that I had to stop.
And so I stopped, at least
dealing out of The Jungle.
I'd walk around and deal here and there
but I couldn't make any money that way.
So I went back to stealing.
Not identities or anything like that,
but I'd steal from the store,
(Ally sniffling)
go sell it to the Chinese.
And then I would still
send my mom money every day
and I still do.
Anything I hustle up every day.
Every single day, any bit of money I get,
I send half of it to her.
Even if it's $15 I send her 10.
(Ally crying)
And my goal is at this
point to get into housing
and I had to get outta Washington
because basically I'm
wanted for escape there.
I'm on the run there.
I had D.O.C. charges from years ago.
(Ally sniffling)
And I skipped out.
And when I got back, they found me,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Anyway they're charging me
with escape and Alaska is,
I'm wanted there for organized
retail theft and fraud.
So both of those are extraditable
charges so I'm scared.
I traveled here under a fake name.
(Ally sniffling)
But I had to get outta Washington
because I'm not afraid to face my charges.
I know that I did wrong
(truck engine rumbling)
and I know I have to be
accountable for that.
I'm not saying that I
don't wanna be, I will.
I will lay in the bed that I've made,
but (Ally sniffling) I want to get my mom
and my daughter taken care
of before that happens.
Because I don't know
how much longer she has.
And that's what I wanna do
(Ally sniffling) so I came here
because I thought I could
probably get into housing
relatively quickly here
because they're under
pretty tremendous pressure
to get the homeless off the streets here.
(Ally sniffling)
So that's what I do.
Every day I hustle up some
money, I send it to my mom.
And in the meantime I'm
trying to get into housing.
I came at the really wrong time
because of this stupid
coronavirus (Ally sniffling).
(Ally laughing)
This coronavirus is making it
so that I can't really do anything,
everything's closed (Ally
sniffling) for housing and stuff.
So I'm just waiting for that to happen.
But yeah, that's where I'm at.
And then a lot of stuff in
between all that happened
that I don't even know where
to start (Ally sniffling).
- [Mark] That's quite a story.
So you're on the run right now?
So who'd be looking for you?
- Alaska and Washington state.
- [Mark] And if they were
to find you, you would?
- I would be in trouble.
I'm looking at 10 to 15 years.
(Ally sniffling)
Yeah.
- [Mark] And putting this video out
won't get you in trouble?
- Well, it could
(Mark clears throat)
if they find me I suppose, but it's not--
- [Mark] But you move
around like you said.
- Facebook everybody knows where I'm at,
it's not like I'm hiding that much.
I don't like running.
I am running, but I'm not.
I don't wanna say, "Here's
where I'm staying at here,
"Come get me."
But...
It is what it is, I guess.
(Ally sniffling)
- Well.
Well Ally thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Yeah, thank you.
(Ally sniffling)
- [Mark] What do you
think in your childhood
was the most powerful factor
in leading you down this path?
(Ally sighing)
- That's a good question.
I had a lot of things that happened
to me that were traumatic
and at the same time, I
had a really good life.
I had horses, I competed
ballroom and Latin dancing,
I had a lot of really great things.
But then like I said, times
were different in the '80s.
I also had uncles and
aunts and family members
that used drugs, dealt drugs, grew drugs,
and I wanted to be part of it all.
I wanted to be part of it all.
And I liked it.
I liked the bad stuff.
I had fun with it.
I guess I was just always
a bad seed I guess.
But in a good way, I'm
a loving good person,
I have a good heart,
but I'm a street person too, I
like the streets, it's weird.
But probably the biggest thing
was the fact that I had
drugs readily available
and people willing to give
them to me at a young age.
And I wanted to be part
of what they were doing.
My aunts and uncles were cool.
My aunt was beautiful,
my uncle was handsome.
(Ally sniffing)
And they had lots of
friends, tons of friends,
and I just wanted to be part of all of it.
Where my grandparents lived in Fairbanks,
there's not very many
kids in that neighborhood,
they're kinda out in the boonies.
So what there was a lot of was teenagers,
drugs, and partying.
And Alaska, I don't
wanna raise my daughter
or my kids there.
My son is already, okay he just turned 18,
he just got out of prison.
He's been in prison since he was 13.
So he's already following
down my footsteps.
And I don't want that for my daughter.
And I know that drugs
are everywhere you go,
but (Ally sniffling) in Alaska
there's not a whole lot of diversity.
There's a lot of darkness,
a lot of cold, and a lot of
depression, and a lot of drugs.
(Ally laughing)
So people and the kids, that's
what they get into there.
Unless you're really, I don't know,
unless you have some amazing
support maybe with your family
do you not, but I think
at least 70% of the kids
probably fall into drugs there.
And I don't think that my
kids will be any different.
My daughter might be
because (Ally sniffling)
because she's had a
rough, tough little life.
She's just the best hearted
little soul in the world.
And I don't believe she
will get into drugs ever
because she's watched me and how it's,
and she loves me to death.
But she knows what my problem is.
She knows that I have a drug issue.
(car engine rumbling)
And someday,
maybe she's gonna hate me for that.
And I hope not, but I
wouldn't blame her if she did
because I've always, it
seems like I put drugs first.
But I am putting her and the kids first.
I put my last son first
by giving him to a mom I know wanted him
and would make him feel
like he was a gift to her.
He was.
I don't wanna ruin my
kids' lives the way I have,
but I have.
But with my childhood
is definitely probably
because the drugs were readily available,
very readily available.
And it's depressing,
nothing to do in Alaska.
Very cold (Ally chuckles) very dark.
(Ally sniffling)
Except for in the summertime,
then it's light all the time.
(Ally laughing)
But...
- [Mark] All right Ally.
Well thank you so much for talking to me.
- Thank you.
- And good luck with--
- With everything?
- With everything.
(Ally laughing)
- Thank you.